Guten Tag, ich heiße Dr. Ahmet Korkmans. Ich bin der Dienstabender aus Erzau, dieser Station.
Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maria Helmading.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname langsam besterbieren?
Ja, Helmading schreibt sich H, E, G, L, M.
R, D, I, N, G.
Helmading.
Okay, Frau Helmading. Wie alt sind Sie?
61 Jahre.
Okay, und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 20. August 1961.
Okay, und wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich wiege 75 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Okay, Frau Helmading.
Ich kann Ihnen helfen.
Ja, Helmading.
Helmading.
Ja, okay, Frau Helmading. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, seit einem Tag geht es mir nicht so gut.
Da habe ich Schüttelfrost und auch Fieber.
Ich habe zweimal erbrochen und ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Ja, 39.
39.
Okay.
Wie sieht Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Das ist gelblich, schneimig.
Ja, gelblich, okay.
Und Frau Helmading, haben Sie Hüsten?
Nein, Hüsten habe ich nicht.
Oder Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, Schmerzen habe ich im Bauch.
Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Wo genau du stärkst die Schmerzen?
Mehr im oberen Bauchteil, so unter den Rippen,
ein bisschen mehr auf der rechten Seite.
Ein bisschen rechten.
Okay.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einordnen auf eine Schmerzstikler?
Schauen wir mal, nur kein Schmerz und zehn untragbare Schmerzen.
Ja, sechs bis sieben.
Momentan haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, aber im Augenblick geht es.
Okay, ich frage, weil vielleicht brauchen Sie
irgendwelche Schmerzmedikamente.
Deswegen habe ich Sie gefragt.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben, zum Beispiel drückend oder ja?
Mehr so ein Druckschmerz, aber manchmal kommt es wie eine Welle.
Also meistens ist es ein Druckschmerz.
Und das strahlt auch in die rechte Schulter etwas aus.
Okay, rechterne Schulter.
Ja.
Okay.
Es ist erst einmal aufgreifen.
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ja, okay.
Okay, Frau Halmardig, haben Sie Probleme bei Sturrgang?
Ich habe seit gestern, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
habe ich dreimal Durchfall gehabt.
Dreimal.
Ja, aber sonst habe ich immer normalen Sturrgang.
Seit gestern ist da so dreimal etwas Durchfall.
Okay, und wie sieht es aus?
Ja, hat irgendwie normale Farbe.
Also es ist jetzt nicht dunkel oder so,
auch nicht blutig oder so, normale Farbe, so gelblich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe mich schon seit einigen Jahren in der Nacht auf die Toilette
regelt, aber sonst habe ich da keine Beschwerden.
Okay, wie ist Ihre Appartite?
Seit gestern nicht gut, sonst ist ja in Ordnung.
Ich darf nicht unbedingt alles essen,
weil ich einen Alterszucker habe.
Sie haben Alterszucker, okay.
Und ich möchte wieder fragen,
diese alle Beschwerden,
plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, relativ plötzlich, innerhalb von einer Stunde.
Okay, bemerken Sie irgendwelche Auslöser,
zum Beispiel vielleicht ein ungewöhnlicher Essen oder...
Ach, ich habe vielleicht,
der Tag davor, da habe ich etwas, glaube ich, zu fettig gegessen.
Also das war, das war im Nachhinein war das nicht so gut, glaube ich.
Vielleicht hängt es damit zusammen, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Gibt es irgendeine,
gibt es die anderen Menschen, die hat gleich Beschwerden?
Nein, nein.
Ist ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, ist mir nicht schwindelig, nee.
Aber sind Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, so ein bisschen Gliederschmerzen,
mit dem Schüttelfrost, was ich gesagt habe,
und dem Fieber, etwas Kopfschmerzen,
vielleicht ist auch dabei, ja.
Aber hauptsächlich habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Ich möchte eine kleine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Wir haben seit gestern Schüttelfrost, Fieber,
Erbrochen und Bauchschmerzen,
mit uns ihre Schmerzen strahlen rekt an Schüttel aus,
und auch wir haben seit gestern dreimal Durchfall.
Ja.
Okay, Frau Hallmeidig, Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie haben die Zuckerkrankheit.
Gibt es noch etwas vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe Nahrungsmittel und Verträglichkeit Milchzucker,
Milchzuckervertrag,
und da muss ich aufpassen mit dem Essen auch.
Okay.
Wie äußert es sich?
Wenn ich zu sehr Milchzuckerhaltige Sachen esse,
dann bekomme ich Bauchschmerzen.
Aber das sind andere Bauchschmerzen,
als jetzt, die ich akut habe.
Normalerweise habe ich ja auch keinen Fieber.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich nehme den Zucker, nehme ich mit Formin ein.
Okay.
In welchen Dosieruch?
850, morgens eine Tablette und abends.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich auch noch Asthma
und ein chronisches Hautexem.
Da sagen die Ärzte, das hängt zusammen.
Viele Asthmatiker haben auch ein Hautexem.
Und dann nehme ich Asthma-Spray,
Bechlometer Sohn und Salbutamol.
Aber Sie, ich nur bei Bedarf nehmen, oder?
Zurzeit nehme ich Bechlometer Sohn 2-mal am Tag
und Salbutamol mehr bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Sie haben die Zuckerkrankheit Asthma
und gibt es noch etwas?
Ja, und Milchzucker.
Okay.
Herr Helm-Werding, sind Sie vollständig geimpft
auch gegen Corona?
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagt, ich bin hier für Deutschland,
Mitteleuropa vollständig geimpft.
Ich brauche zurzeit keine Impfungen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht, auch wegen dem Asthma nicht.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber das ist ganz selten,
wenn ich auf einem Geburtstag oder am Feiertag mal einlöpfe,
aber das ist wirklich vielleicht einmal im Monat.
Ja, okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Es ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben die Erfahrungen mit Rohret?
Nein.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich, glaube ich, so 10 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Dann, da war ich ungefähr 20 Jahre alt,
bin ich mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt
und hatte einen Beinbruch am rechten Unterschäkel.
Und das wurde auch operiert.
Ich habe einen rechten Unterschäkel.
Ja.
Da habe ich dann Schrauben bekommen und eine Platte.
Die wurde dann nach zwei Jahren wieder entfernt.
Okay.
Entschuldigung, ich habe,
wann war es, wann war Ihre Unfall?
Da war ich 20 Jahre alt.
Ja, ich habe das sicher.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Heilmardig,
wir haben fast fertig.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Familie gestanden und Familie geschickt stellen.
Wie ist Ihre familielle Stadt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Ich war mit meinen Kindern.
Ja, drei Kinder.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Zwei von den Kindern haben auch Astma und dieses Haut-Echseen.
Astma und Haut.
Haut-Echseen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite am Fließband und baue Staubsauger zusammen.
Könnten Sie wieder Hause mitnehmen?
Ja, ich arbeite in einer Fabrik.
Die Staubsauger.
Staubsauger herstellt.
Und da arbeite ich in der Produktion.
Und leben Sie Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Die ist 85 Jahre alt.
Die hat auch Alterszucker.
Die hat Arthrose.
Und hat Probleme mit den Knochen.
Die sind sehr brüchig.
Sie hat auch schon häufiger Brüche.
Am Handling und an der Lindenwirbelsäule.
Das macht ihr sehr zu schaffen.
Der Vater war 61 Jahre alt.
Der Vater ist an Magenkrebs gestorben.
Haben Sie ein jubelster?
Ja, ich bin ein Schwester.
Die ist 63 Jahre alt.
Die hat Geilensteine.
Und ist vor zwei Jahren operiert worden.
Ein Bruder ist 59 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch Alterszucker.
Und hat immer wieder Richtanfälle.
Okay, Frau Herr Maardich.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Möchten Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Ja, was können die Ursache dieser Schmerzen sein?
Momentan.
Ich habe nicht genau sagen.
Ich muss ein paar Test machen.
Zum Beispiel Bluttest.
Und Sonografie durchführen.
Und danach könnte ich genau sagen,
was Sie haben.
Aber ich vermute, Sie haben eine
Galamblase.
Über Galamblase Probleme.
Aber ich habe gesagt, ich muss ein paar
Test durchführen.
Danach sprechen wir wieder.
Kann ich jetzt noch etwas trinken?
Ja, ich habe noch etwas trinken.
Leider Sie mussten warten darauf.
Ich würde einen Zugang legen.
Ich gebe Sie eine Flüssigkeit
mit Schmerzmittel.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Gut.
Okay, gut.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Gut.
Ich habe ein Kollege vom Landkreis Andere fragen.
Auf dem anderen Punkt dazu.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Aber ich habe noch keine Schmerzmittel genommen.
ist jetzt, weil es mir auch ein bisschen übel ist, muss ich manchmal etwas aufstoßen.
Ja, aber ich möchte auch gar nichts essen.
Haben Sie Anfang der Schmerzen einmal Zugang oder Gehenwind hab?
Ja, ich hatte jetzt ja seitdem die Schmerzen begonnen haben, seit gestern 3 mal durchfallen.
Da war ich 3 mal, hatte ich Durchfall auf dem Muskel.
Sie haben gesagt, nach dem Essen sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Es kann sein, dass ich am Tag vorher habe ich etwas, ja, das Essen war zu fett, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, ich kann es damit zusammenhängen.
Ich weiß es aber nicht genau. Es ist eine Vermutung.
Erinnern Sie sich erstmal Bauchschmerzen anfangen, dann, Fieber, welche Seite anfangen?
Ja, aber erst kamen die Bauchschmerzen und das Unwohlsein und das Fieber kam dann vielleicht so nach 2 Stunden.
Bitte seid diese Schmerzen verschlechtert, denken Sie?
Die waren relativ schnell da auf der Stärke.
Aber in den letzten Stunden sind sie jetzt nicht wesentlich schlimmer geworden, aber sehr unangenehm.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind wäldenfoll möglich, aber...
Manchmal sind sie etwas wäldenförmig, aber der Schmerz ist immer da.
Ja, manchmal verstärkt er sich so ein bisschen.
Wie sieht Ihre Urin aus?
Ich habe nicht darauf geachtet, kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber ich habe alles und keine Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Ihre Haut oder Augen etwas Veränderung bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind verzerrt.
Können wir als Erzitzkechige anfangen?
Ja, ich versuche.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen sie vorstellen.
Haben Sie dafür Zeit?
Ja, habe ich.
Frau Maria Helmardin ist 61-Jährige.
Sie kam heute seit gestern bestehender Fieber-Schütterfrucks
und hat Schmerzen zu uns verbrochen.
Die Schmerzen sind rechtzeitig in der Epigas-Szene.
Sie sind rechtzeitig in der Epigas-Szene.
Sie liegen bei 6-7 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie ist drückend und wählenformig.
Aber die Patientin hat gesagt, die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Die Schmerzen strahlen recht der Schulter aus.
Die Patienten sind plötzlich aufgeregt.
Sie haben einen fettreichen Essen.
Sie haben eine fettreiche Mahlzeit.
Sie haben die Fieber-Schmerzen im Mund gemessen.
Sie haben die Patientin im Mund gemessen.
Sie klackte über 3-mal die Jahre.
Sie hat keine Blut- oder Farbeänderung bemerkt.
Sie ist ausgelblich.
Ist diese Schmerz-Ereignisse aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen sind erst mal.
Die Patientin hat Laktosintervalenz.
Sie hat viel Bauchsmess.
Aber das ist anders.
Sie leidet an Diabetes meleutisch.
Sie hat eine Diabetes-Berechnung.
Sie nimmt die Patientin Medikamente ein.
Sie nimmt mit Formin 850 ein Mal morgens
und bei der Beklamation 2 Mal.
Sie hat vor Operationen?
Ja.
Als Kind wurde sie appendectomiert.
Mit 20 Jahren hatte er einen Fahrradunfall.
Er hat eine Rechteunterschenke.
Sie hat eine Plattenostiose.
Sie hat eine Aufwendigkeit.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Sie hat eine Pro-Monat-Alkoholität.
Sie haben das systematisch gut gemacht.
Sie haben versucht, die medizinischen Fachausdrücke einzubauen.
Im Anfang ist das nicht so ganz gelungen.
Da haben Sie noch von Bauchschmerz gesprochen.
Sie haben sich vorgelegt, dass sich die Patientin abdomineller Schmerzen
seit einem Tag nach einer fettreichen Mahlzeit,
das ist nur eine Mutmaßung.
Sie haben recht der Oberbauch und Epigastrium.
Laktoseintoleranz oder Laktoseunverträglichkeit
haben Sie als Fachbegriff erwähnt, die Osteoporose,
die Arthose, die Hyperurikemie des Bruders,
die Cholilithiasis der Schwester,
die Magenkarzinom,
die Asthma-Bronchale.
Es gibt eine familiäre Disposition, wenn auch zwei Kinder so etwas haben.
Dann erlebt man das immer wieder,
das Neurodermitis in Verbindung mit Asthma.
Das gibt es relativ oft.
Wenn die Haut besser ist, ist oft das Asthma nicht so gut.
Aber denke, das haben Sie auch gut geführt.
Etwas selteneres vielleicht in der Differenzialdiagnose,
muss man auch mal daran denken, dass es eine rechtsbasale Pneumonie ist.
Und Herr Taiwan-Teamfakt auf jeden Fall?
Ja, auch.
Sie als Kardiologe denken da immer gerne an das Herz, natürlich.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn es der Schmerz rechts ist
und vielleicht Schulter und mit Fieber,
das Fieber ist ja auch da 39 Grad.
Da sage ich jetzt mal so, der Hinterwandinfarkt macht nicht ganz typisch Fieber, oder?
Ja, nicht mit Fieber, aber Rysikofaktüren 61 Jahre.
Und Diabetes melektris, sie ist übergewichtig.
Das sind alles Faktoren.
Also wie gesagt, man könnte die Differenzialdiagnose da ruhig noch ein bisschen erweitern.
Aber Sie haben zwei Differenzialdiagnose genannt.
Und ich denke, das ist auch erstmal, denke ich, ausreichend.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir eine Differenzialdiagnose hinter dem Wandinfarkt nicht schreiben,
aber körperliche Bildgebende untersuchen erstmal eine EKG,
auf jeden Fall durchführen müssen.
Auf alle Fälle.
Und Sie haben ja auch von dem, was ich sehr gut fand, gefragt,
gleich zu Anfang mit den Schmerzen, ob ich die Schmerzen auch aberriere
oder ob Sie jetzt zu stark sind, dass Sie dann mir eventuell etwas geben können.
Ich habe extra nochmal gefragt, da will ich noch darauf achten,
dass Sie sagen zu der Patientin, bitte jetzt nichts mehr essen und trinken.
Sie bekommen von mir jetzt einen Zugang.
Ich habe gefragt, kann ich noch etwas trinken?
Da sollen Sie ganz klar sagen, bitte bleiben Sie jetzt nüchtern.
Sie bekommen von uns Flüssigkeit über eine Infusion.
Das wäre peinlich, wenn der Oberarzt zu Visite kommt
und die Patientin sitzt da gerade und trinkt oder ist gerade vielleicht,
wer weiß was, das wäre dann nicht so gut.
Gut, ja, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Erstablich.
Das ist in einer Woche.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen dafür viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank.
Ich hoffe, wir sehen uns am Mittwoch wieder,
dass es mir von meiner Erkältung hier dann weiter besser geht.
Okay, danke schön.